hello everybody and welcome back to the
last and final playthrough slender
prison I will forgot the name of it
because I'm so you know this is so
beneath me now that my brain has finally
formulated a plot after watching the
explicit instruction from the maker of
the map but anyway yes I am going to
beat this thing because I now know what
to do I'm also gonna incorporate like he
also said confirmed that you need to
look at him to slow him down especially
farther along which hopefully means that
I'll be able to exercise a bit effort
ensue and Harry Bell or to battle won't
ever get a chance to do it again first
try go go go go yeah Oh blazing speed
can't believe it uh so free and there's
the first burger
130 seconds go now
we have begun it has begun
this explains why even though my
strategy was sound my execution with
poor ah ha ha ha ha oh wait it would
have been quicker if I went the other
way damn it
oh well it's fine it's fine you go here
then I go right through here that's - ah
come on that's my route
ah that's you my route that's my route
that's my damn room don't be staying
away my route
damnit clock's ticking die ha ha yeah
not gonna make it not gonna make it
those two rooms there on the right that
I just passed our trawl rooms they
actually leave did nothing up
oh so skilled totally so school actually
this is like the luckiest run besides if
he wasn't standing there everything was
like right in front of my face which is
kind of kind of convenient see all right
it's either in this one no I'm gonna
check ah yes Wow holy hell this is like
unreal this would be the ideal
playthrough Oh
aw crap I made a wrong turn yeah yeah ah
[Music]
oh I'm running out of time I'm about
running out of time
crap crap crap crap crap crap I'm gonna
get how many is so stuck here I'm gonna
get so stuck here he's gotta catch me
and I'm gonna be boned my tri Phi comes
spin around looking dead in the eyes
sockets that aren't there and then go
first a little best yeah personal best I
can sprint backwards yeah okay get this
nail it it right there ya go
[Music]
ah now I am going all this is not the
good way no get back okay cut this way
okay then this way and then sassafras
it's this and then left and then left
again into here ah no rounded corner I
got him I got him nailed come on son
what he like spawned and I got pushed
out of his box balls
all right I probably get I probably took
more than 130 seconds because there was
one thing that I took a wrong turn there
man that was such a good run though
because it was like right there mmm oh
all right maybe I should sprint more I
don't know I don't know I know like oh
it some said like after I don't know
this is this is hurry up maybe I'll try
sprinting a few more times cuz I know I
didn't get anywhere near to running out
of all my sprint do so hopefully I'll be
able to do it in do it again this is
stressful really suck whatever I do with
me hairy mole or
seven of eight obviously to the crew
because I know where they are now
I just kind of look it looking like
nobody's business
bid now go go go
I was almost there is about four turns
away from getting to the end okay it's
not here which means it's over here
the clock does not start until I get the
first one I'm pretty sure but of course
in this playthrough all the pages are
gonna be in bad places horrific Lee
incorrect spawns no if not that way over
here oh all I don't wait what wait
that's not right no no no no yeah it is
here ah cuz this is that crazy room
alright never go go go go go go go go
D'Argo's come on you think okay now
y'all go Guinea I really want to spring
right now but I know that I should not
and that guy gets aggressive once you
get higher up in the pages okay so let's
see if you're here enough of course it's
not here why would it be here that being
here would be way too convenient could
it be in here well I don't see it but I
gotta check the sink of course no I
think on this one these ones it's all in
the bed or something so I always on the
bed oh crap crap
where is it oh no oh no oh no don't be
like that
it's gotta be here oh thank you ah I saw
you I tell you okay now through here
no through here let's mix that up
running out of time must hurry a lot
require her eNOS yes yes bug bug boo
this man oh I'm gonna get this don't you
worry
[Music]
hi everybody we hurry below
hopefully that's the last time after say
her name not that there's anything wrong
with your name mr. bang
prisoner
oh I'm really got my game isn't lagging
anymore left all eight photos well isn't
that so lovely what am i scrapbooking
come on it's not here again boo boo if
it's over here then I got a run farther
to get to the next one
OOP yeah I can't I honestly can't say
that I'm in love with that it kind of I
don't know the whole 130 seconds things
I'm not I'm not a huge fan of it because
it kind of breaks it down into not so
much of a an adventure makes it just
kind of like you have to take a specific
path I mean a cool thing about the whole
place is that you know you're kind of
stranded and dark and it like reduces
the amount of time you could play the
game I mean I think it was kind of fun
just exploring around for like 10 whole
minutes just running around panicking
because slender's like a round enter
every corner but now it's just like you
have a countdown until you die and I'm
not a huge fan of that but I still want
to beat this game don't get me wrong
because it deserves to be beaten not
there I think I saw it did I see it no I
did not
I lied it's in the same thing nope
AHA yeah yeah there we go yeah see you
kind of forces you to like just it
forces you to keep moving I mean not in
a way that's kind of scary but it
distracts from the experience a lot I I
was having more fun you know back when I
was first when I first played something
because I had no idea what's going on it
seemed like a great map because there
was so many places to get lost and I
thought that that alone is part of the
good thing about the game but given the
fact that as soon as you pick up
anything it's instantaneous and I went
the wrong way again I
it's instantaneous got ya mechanic is
you know yeah
[Music]
okay damn it I got a check sink and
toilet ah there it is
yeah uh I got it hi hi buddy
hi friend oh oh no you don't know nope
nope I got here we go ha ha ha
see ah there's the other one
glue and then get the one at the end
here I'm probably not gonna make it out
of this room
because I mean is for some reason when I
was looking at the strategy and the map
and everything if I got around a corner
oh what's that oh you suck
oh not even good yeah it's looking at a
scratchy and reminded me a lot of like
raiding strategies for more the Warcraft
you know very explicit written out you
follow this recipe and you win part of
what makes a slender mass great ah and
that again
come on you Oh lag about I'm gonna start
running now cuz I need to I need I go
the wrong way I did go the wrong way no
I did not I did not go why am I still
frame oh hello no I thought you moving
okay now I basically I'm just gonna be
spinning the whole time or something
don't kill me here buddy
7:08 again man ah I mean there's nothing
wrong with like a recipe to win that's
fine I mean strategy is a good thing I
kind of like the I don't know I don't
know I'm not criticizing the guy because
I mean it's a unique thing I'm not gonna
bash any attempt to make something
unique that's good but that doesn't
always mean that it's gonna be better
you know
step you can take steps in the wrong
direction but you know I don't make
these maps before I don't have a say in
it heck I don't even know what's best
hair evil or so that's just my my two
cents on the ladder
[Music]
all right I think I got a I think I got
a like I think I'm getting run down on
the timer especially at the seven pages
so as soon as I hit this first one I
think I'm actually gonna start sprinting
and of course it's not on that one again
because I want to like speed up the
clock because I I don't want to hit that
one thirty when I'm like two steps from
the exit that would suck because there's
like it's like a it's not that bad
getting from one place to the exit here
but no this is all crucial okay yep I
don't know this is probably this might
be a bad read bad but I'm just gonna try
it I mean part of what I like about a
game is being able to experiment and
sort of figure out what works and what
doesn't
ah I've been saying too much about it
it's a good game don't get me wrong it's
a great game
and I appreciate everything that mr.
mark Steen and everyone else on the team
has done to help make this an experience
for everybody so thumbs up Oliver in
case you didn't notice I always say
something nice even if I have something
to criticize I still like to say nice
things oh hey excuse me why oh yeah I
know I know
I'll be right yeah okay that's nice
thank you
all right now this is the way that I
wanted to go before because it cuts out
right here
AHA right to the fourth photo just like
that and that way I can go down here
through here cut straight through ads or
cuts off a few seconds makes it a little
bit better okay I'm a safe sprint so
that I get through this area okay I
should be fine
[Music]
okay I'm making good time on this one
I'm making good time
I think the sprinting method kind of
kind of helps out you needed Ben if he
does there are ways to counteract him I
mean if he sees you early on so long as
he doesn't spawn right on top of ya
you're okay because if you turn around
to look at him you could be okay
[Music]
ah come on what the hell is that [ __ ]
balls what am I gonna do right friggin
there god damn it damn it come on go
away man
that's a bad place good thank you ah ha
okay ah [ __ ] oh no oh no oh no oh no
okay
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go oh that was this
inconvenient that was like the worst
place for him to be absolute worst mm
god I wanna beat this I wanna beat it so
badly
ah
harima lore
I'm gonna get this I'm gonna get this if
I had not got run into him in that way
on my other places you know how I got to
seven of eight because I was looking it
through that one I was doing fantastic
okay maybe I'm not gonna start sprinting
in the beginning but I am gonna start
sprinting once I hit four once I hit
four I'm gonna start looking at oh thank
you picture right here perfect Oh
perfect oh this is going to be a good
plate
okay now let's rock it through this song
[ __ ] come on come on come on
nope ah all right all right I mean when
you think about it a hundred and thirty
seconds is not a lot of time she doesn't
even give you time to really explore and
appreciate that the area you're in I
mean I don't mind being on the clock I
loved high rated for a long time so I
love these kind of intense strategies
hardcore stuff and that's fine with me
[Music]
so I'm not complaining
[Music]
cuz I'm gonna beat this yes right here
flip around get gone
sorry for I am out the door with more we
will wait no oh crap
ah but which way do I go I'm totally
totally turned myself around I think I'm
in the right area am i yes I am okay
nevermind I'm okay I'm okay
okay it's got to be in this cell here I
lost it right there not paying attention
that's what I'll do it to you what what
no this has got to be it
it says there's only two spawns right
here here and I miss it I missed it
didn't I I missed it didn't I ah how did
I miss that edge okay got him alright
moving moving okay ah come on
oh you're right in my wet fine yeah Oh
screw you good good good get out of here
[Music]
save Sprint for coming out of here
hmm he's not giving me a break guys he
is not he's all up in my grill now six
of eight last ones in a guaranteed spot
then it's just number eight or the
second last ones and a guaranteed spot
then it's just number eight on oh I got
to boom just like that nailed it nailed
it to the frickin wall so I'm gonna I'm
so sprinting out of this next room but
this isn't right aw crap I took a wrong
turn oh no oh no oh no I took a wrong
turn oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me oh no I took a
wrong turn
oh wait no I'm catching up okay I'm
catching up I'm catching up ah where is
he where is he
[ __ ] ah come on
just grab and go Robin go okay
then up this way hmm one more try huh uh
this will be my last attempt guys I'm
not gonna kill myself over this one I
mean if I don't make it I don't make it
that's just the way it is I'm gonna
actually look at the clock so I know
exactly how much time I have for some
reason like oh and there we go the game
crashed all right all right that's a
sign that's a sign I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna that's my that was my last attempt
it's under prison I don't see how I
could have done any better in terms of
time management I got turned around for
a little bit there actually no I I
missed I missed Oh
all right fine one more try that'll be
it one more try and that'll be it this
is my last attempt guys
oh just give me a second I will load it
up in uno momento and fraps in three two
one
all right so this is my last attempt I
know I know that actually I don't know
if I hit the timer or if I hit the limit
I I don't know he was just there all of
a sudden
the last one everyone do it with me
Harry Miller I really did it
all right game face
no joking around this time no skipping
over get the booty in my mind that's a
good way to start
Paige isn't here photo whatever you want
to call it all right 936 is there any
way I could like optimize this fruit
it's just nice that one leg in the back
alley where that photo is that's what
kills you that's what kills you on time
[Music]
mmm I'm like totally totally totally
totally into this see come on come on oh
it hasn't been in the first room since I
first tried it never it's gotta be I
gotta go in each one of these duck in
there it is there it is okay
duck in duck through this room to get
through the wall and it's a little
quicker I don't know maybe I don't know
I don't know go straight down here take
a left
whoops Oh didn't know right click did
that you know I haven't even been
playing long enough for a light bulb to
break
so I mean if you're really trying to win
oh wait no I got it turn around that's
right
kill some time or get some time back all
right come on being this left one being
this left one being this left one yes
yes yes all right now I'm starting to
sprint all right doing good doing good
good scut spread all right time is good
I've been fairly decent on the routes
and fairly lucky with finding them
except for the first one was in a bad
spot five of eight six will be in the
room to the left up here okay I bet he's
gonna jump behind me I know it is he's
done before
ha haaa [ __ ] okay and then it's in here
somewhere
it's gotta be it's gotta be in here
there's a light bulb come on
who's supposed to be in there what's it
what oh crap
where is it ah [ __ ] well I don't know
what the guy said it was gonna be in
here or in there and I can't go on
without number five ah yeah yeah I'm
boned okay number five is not our number
six it's not here I want to do I just
know the place for it to be oh boy I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead just dead
oh good just the way it is I'm dead I'm
a dead man
oh come on I can go through there I'm a
dead man up here we go there he is
hi buddy friend Oh
now let's just carry on see what you do
I think this is in a this is like over
okay whatever whatever buddy
you don't scare me oh hi hi friend
that's got to do it that's got to do it
I'm throwing in the towel on slender
prison this is my last attempt I'm sorry
folks I didn't get it it's just a shame
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done you know I was
still gonna look forward to carnival
don't get don't get me wrong when I save
it you know I have some criticisms about
this type of game style in this type of
way slender behaves it's not bad by
anything it's different and it makes it
a more intense for the first time but
you saw at the end that at the end there
it was very rigid and mechanical I
wasn't even startled anymore because it
was just a recipe you know and part of
what makes slender great I think is that
it's you don't know you don't know like
I died in that room every single time
because it's just you know that's it's
the way it was
I don't happen with that six-page there
but it just wasn't there for some reason
um but you know I think that what makes
learner great is just the fact that you
can go anywhere and you don't know where
he's gonna be but he was very very very
predictable in that one once you
understood how it worked he was
exceptionally predictable so anyway
that's just my two cents on don't be
offended if the developers watch this at
all I don't know if they will but don't
be offended that some that's just my
take on it I don't make these games I
don't make any games I'm just a guy who
plays games so take my opinion at what
it is
I just got who plays games I can I I'm a
not mean anything so anyway thanks again
everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye